[Music]
i was at a uh at a bookstore uh this
weekend they still have those yes there
are still a few left
and there are a lot of holiday leftovers
on sale you notice if you go to a
bookstore now there's just tons of books
that they're selling for next to nothing
because they didn't sell during the
holidays and most of them are coffee
table books that were supposed to be
gifts and nobody bought them and they
were so cheap i bought a bunch of them i
thought i'd share them with you now in a
little piece we're going to call new
coffee table books
[Applause]
fun
this is the first one i got i love this
one it's called newt's future wives
it's the women
newt will love and then get tired of and
it's beautiful oh the pictures look good
look at the diversity the diversity of
each other
one of those women is almost brunette
yes
and then uh check out this one not so
popular the big book of filled in
crossword puzzles
they've all been filled in ahead of time
and uh i love this because oh i do too
just a whole weekend of erasing yeah it
was nice
uh fantastic this one i loved it's the
uh it's a book called satellite photos
of dogs
absolutely love this book get in there
close i want to see you can actually see
the chihuahua
that's why we have high definition
televisions
but this is a keeper i'm going to hang
on to this and hey jimmy happy birthday
oh thanks
all right
remember those famous photos by anne
gettys of babies in vegetable and animal
costumes
well here's a new book called anne
getty's babies all grown up and
[Laughter]
you think you've been in that the whole
time he's been there the whole time
he's saying please kill me
and then look they even have this
picture on the back which i absolutely
absolutely love
the adorable three babies turned into
those three groups
anyway that's a cute hey jimmy another
one for your birthday
better back up the car here's a great
one this is a coffee table book called
accidental iphone photos
just beautiful
and really it's just the gorgeous thing
incredible incredible you've got i take
that one all the time
every picture tells no story tells no
story at all
those are nice uh oh this is fantastic
what a beautiful book absolutely
gorgeous it's a must-have
gorgeous sunsets in braille this one's
called
you see
oh it's the japanese island of hokkaido
yes it is
gorgeous gorgeous the the oranges oh
beautiful burnt umbers
you watch it with your burnt umbers
uh this one i just this one it might be
one of my favorites so i'm gonna this is
a keeper jimmy vivino's not getting this
one that's right sir anthony hopkins
rides the world's scariest roller
coasters
[Applause]
oh and look at him
he does not lose his cool the whole time
unruffled yeah i've been through every
single page of this book and i'm telling
you this guy
does not get rattled
[Applause]
uh oh this is a fantastic book this is a
must-have you should get this one it's
called people buying phil collins
greatest hits
[Applause]
there's nobody who's happy to be in this
book
nobody right an entire book of people
and then uh gotta mention this one
finally this one's fantastic it's jesus
photobombs prom pictures
here's jesus
they don't even know he's there
he's such a prankster and look the book
only gets better when you really see
these
trampoline yeah
also
you know what's great he's just
levitating above that trampoline